Florida Governor Ron DeSantis not
holding back against democrat-led cities
and states the Republican leader ripping
into blue State policies during a fiery
second term inaugural speech yesterday
the policies pursued by the states have
sparked a mass Exodus a productive
Americans from these jurisdictions with
Florida serving as the most desired
destination a Promised Land of Sanity we
reject this woke ideology we seek
normalcy not philosophical lunacy we
will not allow reality facts and Truth
to become optional we will never
surrender to the woke mob Florida is
where woke goes to die and the numbers
appear to back up what DeSantis is
saying about that mass Exodus Americans
are loading up their U-Hauls and fleeing
Democratic states both California and
New York experienced a six-figure
population loss since 2020 and
conservative red States like Texas and
Florida appear to have absorbed them
both have seen growth well into the
six-figure range and I think taxes also
have a big thing to do with that and
judge Governor hokel last week I believe
it was said we got to stop this like
this is not a good thing this is not a
good trajectory but yet doesn't have any
proposals to do that we have hocal we
have hokel let's watch I wish not just
jump on a bus and head down to Florida
where you belong okay get out of town
get out of town because you don't re you
don't represent our values
you are not New Yorkers we must and will
make our state safer we have to make our
state more affordable and New Yorkers
are just struggling to pay rent food and
gas to get to their jobs they're hurting
and we must reverse the trend of people
leaving our state in search of lower
costs and opportunities elsewhere what
happened to her and judge you saw the
light uh you know what it would be nice
to say if you believe she saw the light
but she clearly hasn't seen the light
all she's doing is she's politicking all
right if she were worried about crime
what is driving most people out of New
York and you know was the number one
issue during the last campaign she would
be on the record and say we're going to
change the bail or the cashless fail law
it's not working crime is only
catapulted with the law with the change
in that law if she said something like
that I would say that she's had a change
of heart but she hasn't she's a hater
she's the kind of hater who says get out
of New York if you're a republican
you're not our kind of person go to
Florida you know what well you're going
to have to eat your ear your your words
because in the end the people went to
Florida them because there were lower
taxes there's no state income tax you
got a governor who's fighting for you
making sure that your kids aren't seeing
anything portographic in grade school
nobody's talking to them about their
sexual identity and you know there are
no automatic totalitarian coveted
restrictions you know and all the stuff
that the totalitarians like that like
her they don't have in Florida everybody
I know in Florida are so happy to be
there they love it yeah and we've been
watching this for a while since we've
been on the five like remember that
U-Haul costs from San Francisco to Texas
the one way was like so high and there's
more research showing that it's getting
worse I love that she's begging right
now that hopeless begging she reminds me
of a really stupid guy who dumps his
girlfriend because he thought since he
has this girlfriend he can have any girl
right he's like you know I'm in a
relationship and The Grass Is Always
Greener and now she's gone and he's a
sobbing mess she's him she's now looking
up all the exes you know for emotional
support please please come back I was
wrong but the fact is there's no cost
benefit advantage to being in a city the
blue cities have now become cities that
blow a lot and a lot has to do with you
know the crime and stuff and I feel like
this anus's speech writers are watching
my show because he's comprehending he's
comprehending the Zeitgeist which is the
spirit or mood of a country Jesse thank
you at a particular time I'm going to
write that down and the Zeitgeist is
that you and you can feel it that we're
all done with the woke you know it's
kind it's over and before it used it
basically blew through America and it
scared the crap out of people and nobody
and it's been and so we all just sat
there and we said oh my God you know
cancel culture it's here to stay but
then all you had people started to
realize no if you actually just share
the risk remember we said that if you
share the risk and you face the bully it
just collapses and now I think you know
you know he's he's at the tip of the
spirit right now with Lord It's good to
see meanwhile The Burbs we're talking
about a flip the burbs are now cooler
than the cities you still get the great
restaurants you got you know music you
got and you don't have Theater which is
great so anyway no crime no homelessness
and you're in in the suburbs you know
cities might be dead and Jesse one thing
that DeSantis has that other Republicans
in Washington don't have is this ability
to be separate from like what's going on
on the house Side Oh I thought you're
gonna say the great hair oh because he
had a nice set of hair on that I didn't
know it was that good but it looked
pretty good and you're right he's kept a
safe distance from all the drama in
Washington which is good for him do you
remember what it was like when we were
at the Patriot Awards in Florida yeah
how it felt different the hotel we don't
need to get into all that right do not
go it felt more fun it felt Freer the
freedom felt Freer and I can imagine if
we were there maybe not half the year
but one day more than half the year how
great that would be for our taxable
income and I don't know if everybody
knows this but I'm taking my taxable
income yeah and making a mass Exodus to
the state of New Jersey not a red state
but a red dur State than New York and
I'm not going to miss the city I'm not
going to miss the Ubers the traffic the
excessive tipping at every coffee shop
I was in the West Village for a while
remember I got beer poured over me yes
yelled things at me I was the real
victim those those Fox and Friends guys
can be pretty mean but it's definitely
going to be nicer to be in the suburbs
where I'm appreciated more and respected
by people that like me Jessica do
Democrats not care about this kind of
Exodus from Blue states to Red because
they figure that the people who are
leaving are ones they don't want to have
there anyway like what Hogle said in
July no there's I mean it's obviously
contributing to some degree in the
Florida example the fact that now it's
ruby red right I mean Florida is now a
place that Democrats cannot contend on
the same level that they used to be able
to but you do have to question whether
people are they're making these changes
but are there politics changing right so
a lot of people who went to Texas they
went to Austin right which is a bright
blue City in there
and they're living the same lives but
better quality of life in terms of their
houses are bigger and their kids schools
were open and were open throughout covet
and will continue to be and that's
something that I really think was
driving this I understand the taxes is a
big deal
and the crime is a big deal but what it
really was for people at least in my
cohort with young children that they
wanted their kids in school and they
were going to go to a place where that
was going to happen for them so it's
obviously a trend it's troubling
especially High tax states like
California and New York we can't afford
to be losing all these rich people right
that's basically what Kathy hokels
saying like rich people please come home
because we need to tax you so please
come home please come home it's a phone
home but the cities are still great just
in defense of them and granted no one
pours beer on me in the West Village but
no I'm so nice she is so nice nobody
pour beer on her all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else